today's starting pitcher for the tigers
is matthew boyd making his 11th start of
the season he's coming off a pretty good
one last time got a win against kansas
city last tuesday let's have a good
outing try to repeat what you did last
time
here's cesar hernandez swinging a mess
matthew boyd sits him down for out
number two
records his first strikeout on a slider
with two away here's jose ramirez
the 1-1 on the ground to paredes he'll
hurry the throw
and get ramirez by a step clean
first for matthew boyd and a nice start
for detroit
carlos carrasco on the mound for the
indians carlos been pitching very well
in his last four games
carrasco fastball cutter curve slider
and that devastating split chain
that'll bring up willy castro chase the
breaking ball in the dirt
and leone will throw down the first two
away
and here's miguel cabrera nice pitch
beautiful pitch back-to-back strikeouts
for carrasco the tigers go in order
or scoreless after one humorous way to
end
the first for carlos carrasco and miguel
cabrera
one long distance kiss and a wave
goodbye doing the same
here's jorge bonifacio he's over 10.
here's the one-two pitch
check swing did he go yes on the appeal
at first
and so the slider got bonifacio fishing
here's niko goodrum
good from batting left-handed swings and
misses at the high heat
and carrasco has struck out four tigers
in the first two innings
willie castro batting left-handed now
two on
two out and the 2-2 pitch is swung on
and missed so carrasco gets out of it
gets his fifth strikeout of the
afternoon and after three
still no score in motown the chef told
you earlier about
spencer turnbull last night having five
one two three innings well we're only in
the fourth but matthew has a chance
for his four straight he's on cruz right
now tough out
maybe the toughest out in their lineup
and jose ramirez
paredes nice job matthew boyd has faced
12 hitters and retired all of them
now the indians have a promising start
to the ending going with runners at
first and second
nobody out and now it's jordan luplow
who fly to right
his first time up big breaking ball
swung on line drive left field base hit
that will score santana racing around
third
he comes across home plate and luplos
rbi
single gives the indians a one-nothing
lead
and now there's two down drive up one
nothing delino de shields will be the
batter here's boyd's pitch
and it's swung on lined into center
field getting down
base hit for de shields it's bobbled out
there by reyes
from reyes scores also scoring on the
play is
luplow and into second is de shields
a huge two out two run base hit for
delino de shields and
fernandez has struck out grounded out
and he's down in the counter ball in two
strikes
matthew boyd had a perfect game going
until the fifth
the pitch a swing and a line shot to
center
going back reyes he leaps it's over his
head
it'll go all the way to the wall and
hernandez can fly into third
except he stops at second
a line drive that reyes kind of froze on
and then when he tried to go back on it
sailed over his head
and cesar hernandez leads the league in
doubles with
18 but that had to be a triple here's
jose ramirez two ground outs to third
he'll bat right-handed
now the pitch and it's swung on drill to
left down the line it goes
go on into the bullpen and the indians
laid it five to nothing
and jose ramirez continues to beat the
living daylights out of the tigers staff
his 14th homer his 36th rbi
and jose ramirez in this series
against detroit this weekend in the
motor city
now has eight hits three of them home
runs
and he has eight rbis hernandez
now at second and with two down jose
ramirez will bat
right-handed now the 2-0 pitch he swings
and sends one in the air
deep left center long run for reyes the
center fielder's out of room
it's in the indians bullpen he's done it
again
jose ramirez for the second time in this
series
has a two-homer game it's his fourth
multi-homer game of the season and the
indians lead it
seven to nothing and the little man
is still a one-man wrecking crew and
ramirez now 15 homers 38 rbis
bring up boston romine
struck him out with a breaking ball his
11th
k of the day carlos carrasco with seven
innings of one hit
shutout baseball willy castro
oh there's a broken bat get through the
left and it will get through
hey we're on the radius will score
thanks to the rbi
single from willy castro now here's
miguel cabrera the 2-1
fly ball right center field this one's
hit hard it's deep to right center and
that ball is gone a home run wow miguel
cabrera put a charge into that one
deep right center where the wall angles
out
number seven is a two run shot
and it's now seven three that that was
miggy right there
at his best right there ball away
front arm hitting didn't try to pull it
and boy did he get all of it stayed
behind it
barreled it up goodbye good room two for
five in his career against brad hand
drives one to right lupus going back
it's over his head and off the wall
bonifacio's gonna be waved home ramon
santiago's got that windmill going
bonifacio's gonna score and the tigers
have pulled within 7-4
two down in the ninth hand at 24 pitches
the indians with a 7-4 lead and paradise
now the 1-0 and it's swung on lifted in
the air to center this will do it
ball game the shields makes the grab
and it got a little dicey but the
indians take
three out of four from the detroit
tigers they reduced their magic number
to
three to clinch a playoff spot and they
stopped detroit today by a final score
of 7-4